the nature of i guess a holiday and
celebrating a holiday
is really more about what you value and
so
if they value something else i guess so
in that case you would say that the
you know neo-nazis celebrating hitler's
birthday is just as valid as christmas
legitimate christmas yes
change my mind christmas edition well
kwanzaa edition really yeah not so much
yeah it's just as valid we'll get to
that in a second so
um obviously kwanzaa not an issue is
near and dear to my heart as pro-life
the second amendment the gender issue
free speech but
a lot of people don't know anything
about kwanzaa and i think we've all
grown up in school certainly i did in
high school and college it was put
alongside christmas hanukkah kwanzaa
as though every holiday is just as
legitimate or as valid as the next one
um i don't think that's a good way to
look at the world i think it's incorrect
i think kwanzaa's fake it's a scam and
most of you don't know anything about
the holiday that you think
is kwanzaa comment below do you think
that all holidays are the same does it
matter
are these just festivities where you you
give gifts or are they important sort of
cultural
landmarks if you will comment i want to
hear from you story about me with
kwanzaa i did the voice of the brain on
arthur
i didn't know until the christmas album
that the brain was a black bear
and i had to learn about clowns as well
and do the kwanzaa wrap
one's a wrap i was so bad they cut my
verses and replaced it with backgrounds
not surprising
hey come together now it's kwanzaa time
i almost didn't work for you over that
song
i was fired very quickly as a child as
you should have been
voice actor so comment below also change
my mind army lottocuttershop.com you can
buy the shirt topic of your choice
and engage in conversation don't wear it
if you're just going to be bombastic ass
but if you want to engage in
conversation change some minds over the
holidays it's a great way to do it
kwanzaa is it fake
[Music]
all right so we just had a session on
why there are only two genders now i am
asserting the opinion that kwanzaa is
not as legitimate of a holiday as
christmas
i am open to my mind being changed i
will tell you my opinions on this one
aren't quite as strong but it was
seasonal
christian nice to meet you christian
here you can hold the microphone someone
complain
i don't think they work there's people
no it does work is that the mic working
yeah last time someone complained i
didn't give them the microphone but
often people say they don't want to hold
it so if you can hold it up closer to
your uh
um sorry what's your name again uh
christian chris christian
yeah okay you said you had a question so
that just i don't believe kwan's as
legitimate as a holiday
as christmas and it's changed my mind uh
firstly i don't quite want to change
your mind yet i was curious
what you meant when you said legitimate
like what makes a holiday
legitimate in your mind sure um i guess
in this instance
let's say i don't believe it's a holiday
that should be celebrated
with passion or fervor uh you know
christmas and listen let's acknowledge
right off that we don't necessarily know
when christ was born right it could be a
celebration because of the winter
solstice and the babylonians so let's
let's go with that
but uh christ had a historical impact
that was significant
that was very positive whether you think
christians
are good or not christ himself there's
very little argument that he was a bad
historian and of course it's been
celebrated in societies for a very long
time and steeped in tradition
based on a legitimate historical figure
christ didn't create christmas
people created christmas and honestly i
see what you mean kwanzaa
do you know well so that's why i believe
christmas is a legitimate holiday would
you like to know why i don't believe
kwanzaa is uh yeah sure
unless you wanted to take the take the
ball there and run with it well
um firstly i just say i'm not very
educated on kwanzaa but
i'm more i'm more no i don't i'm more
interested
in uh calling a holiday legitimate
because
like i think firstly you need to define
a holiday and so
a holiday i guess is sort of like a
celebration yes
based often on like a value or something
like
historical figure or something you're so
yeah it's solving some event like
winter solstices some some along that
line
and so essentially for something to be a
holiday
it really just means that you personally
value it and celebrate it
well so not necessarily as a society
right so
with the united states we celebrate
christmas because it's 1600 years of
tradition and 92 percent of americans
celebrate it
now you're african-american is that yeah
did you prefer african-american black
person of color i don't want to get the
aclu
okay black so you said black see i had
some one time one person say how dare
you say black
this is where we've come to as a country
um so 92 percent of americans celebrated
uh you're black you probably celebrate
christmas uh
i don't sell it late you don't sell for
christmas every day okay even a higher
percentage of black americans celebrate
christmas than white americans um
less than four percent of
african-americans celebrate kwanzaa it's
likely closer to one percent yeah
nobody celebrates it now we're told that
it's as legitimate and we teach it
alongside
christmas or uh hanukkah or passover
are you aware of the history of kwanzaa
uh no no i'm not
okay is anyone here well well keep it
between well just you and i
uh and then after that we can go because
there's one a lot of people don't know
kwanzaa was invented
in the 60s i knew that much either 66 or
68.
do you know by whom uh no i don't recall
okay just one question
who was the inventor of kwanzaa
i know stop it
irrelevant
malana karenga yes malana karenga known
by his real name as
ron everett everett invented kwanzaa
in the 1960s now uh he's the man who
invented it right
himself so let's say christ invented
christmas was like you're all going to
celebrate my birthday
right i don't demand you celebrate my
birthday with other people who honored
him
ron everett wanted other
african-americans to celebrate kwanzaa i
don't know if you know it's not an
african deal
yeah it's entirely african-american um
ron everett based the ideas of quant if
you look at their practices actually
it's far it it's rooted deeply in far
left communism and marxism even
mentioned cuban and chinese uh
as the roots for kwanzaa okay this was a
man who was deeply troubled
this was a man who actually was charged
with using two women of his black
nationalist party forcing
them to put soldering irons up against
their skin beating them with electrical
cords a really really bad
you don't mind if i cut it in that
series that seems like a bit of
an ad hominem so it's kind of he did he
was strong i know but it's like
it's so irrelevant to your point is all
i wanted to say
it's not because here's why let me ask
you this how did you feel about the
confederate statues
it's confederate statues um i feel like
my position with confederate statues is
very odd
because i could definitely see like the
it
it's it's almost like a swastika it's
like it's just a symbol and at the end
of the day it's completely meaningless
okay but it's it's kind of hard to deny
the fact that
there is a history attached to it sure
and so
and that history can make people feel
very uncomfortable yes and so i felt
like
um there was justification to remove the
confederate statues okay because it made
people not feel safe
i feel like as a society that's sort of
like a goal we should push forward to
make people feel safe
and so but i didn't feel like taking
them down just
breaking them and things like that
wasn't necessarily justified because i
feel like
particularly it was more about the
artwork for me i felt like
the statues were very intricate artwork
don't hold here
because you got a soft voice it's very
soothing but i hear in the mic
um well look the reason i asked this and
i understand that's nuanced right
yeah now let's remove the nuance okay
and the reason the nuance like for
example a lot of the founding fathers we
celebrate
in memoriam because they were virtuous
even if they had slaves like i think we
can all agree george washington did some
great stuff
yeah i think we can all agree even
though abraham lincoln
right had slaves at one point yeah did
some good stuff right
so the reason that we celebrate a lot of
these people is because they have some
good qualities
yeah but i understand the nuance now how
would you feel
if there were or what would you think if
there were a holiday dedicated
to someone who was a slave owner who
abused their slaves
who called for violence against other
who really was an overall bad person but
didn't have any redeeming value
would you say that that holiday is as
legitimate as christmas
i think i would say yes and that that i
say that
because of the nature of i guess a
holiday and celebrating a holiday
it's really more about what you value
and so
if they value something else i guess so
in that case you would say that the
you know neo-nazis celebrating hitler's
birthday is just as valid as christmas
legitimate as christmas
yes i would well in that sense then
maybe even i would just disagree
i mean as a societal holiday kwanzaa is
not as legitimate i think i think that's
really where our disagreement is i think
i think the core issue is that you find
holiday is to be
for it to be legitimate it has to be
societally accepted
well let me ask social media should we
teach the celebration of hitler's
birthday
alongside in history class christ
or i would say washington or the
emancipation proclamation
should we teach this as a holiday i was
saying no
okay but i also would say kwanzaa so
it's a legitimate holiday
i would say that we shouldn't teach
kwanz about those who say that we
shouldn't teach christmas
and so i don't think that it's
particularly more legitimate in that
sense
okay i just think i think we disagree
but uh i appreciate your consistency on
that
may i ask though why do you think
christmas should be taught in classrooms
well i think christmas is celebrated a
because of the founding of our country
the idea of judeo-christian principles
against 1 600 years
of established tradition and 92 percent
of americans celebrate christmas
yeah but it's sort of like a separation
of church and state thing it's like
sure that that makes a lot of sense to
teach your kids about christmas
yeah but you should teach your kids
about christmas it's not
it doesn't belong really in the school
does that feel like it's i mean
listen there are many you're many kids
maybe don't necessarily celebrate
kwanzaa
yeah if that many kids weren't involved
in the you know the french revolution
they're learning about it but they're
learning about christmas because there's
1600 years at least of celebrated
tradition and 92 percent of americans
they need to learn about it
my issue is when we teach it teaches
though because of political correctness
kwanzaa
is the same in tradition in scope in
practice
or in value because it's not that's my
position oh i see i see what you
yeah okay well thank you though yeah i
think we
agree on some and just i appreciate your
consistency and how respectful
it's been been productive yeah that was
interesting thank you
christian uh yes thank you christian
yeah you can place out there thank you
hey if you like this video subscribe or
more importantly support
by joining mug club for the daily show
lottoworthgator.com
mug club because that's the only way we
can do this anymore with youtube
squeezing us apparently they don't like
civil
change my mind discussions i'm in a
onesie by the way because it's christmas
and you can't
judge me louderscrider.comclub
you're still judging i can see it